thank you everyone that was we've been
here a while and we've heard quite a bit
I think we should open it up to other
people we've got a microphone there I
know you don't like that kind of thing
but we'll have to do it that way just
come up to if you feel free to come up
to the microphone if you have questions
keep them focused and short so that
people can have a chance to talk and
then we'll take a few of those at a time
and let anyone answer so okay so my
question for all the panelists if you
have any notes about having an event
like this the irony that Trina has
mentioned but having an event like this
not just in an elitist space but also a
settler colony in Harlem and also a
space that is highly policed and a group
of us who were denied entrance for
whatever reasons before the event
started were actually asked by the
organizers to leave the floor
immediately and I'm quoting verbatim and
then security approached approached us
and asked us to leave and when we asked
what rules are being enacted and that we
would be happy to oblige if the roads
are pointed out we were asked for our
IDs he took a picture of my ID and I was
threatened that my name would be given
to my Dean which is I mean I gave them
my near happy I mean if he would give my
name's oh I'd invent it would only make
the point clear and then security
reinforcements came to deal with this
apparent threat security threat so i
don't i'm not trying to Center ourselves
here because again we are privileged
students in an elitist university and
part of colonizing Harlem but my
question is more about this sir this
system of policing that is proliferating
and promoting itself even in an event
about cultural politics thank you so
much
um yes what impact has been studied i
knows who have disabilities in the
prison system the question so we have
one about our location and the activity
of carcel politics here in our space and
this is about disability issues in well
I mean those prisoners who have
disabilities has it been started how
they've been impacted we're going to
take a few questions so that they can
answer all together so we have
disability thank you
it's hard to follow those up I have a
lot of questions don't worry I won't
read all this um these are my notes I
guess the first question is and this
might be redundant perhaps if it was
covered early on the talk i was also
denied admission initially then later on
I don't understand how things work at
the school I'm not a student here but
anyways I wanted to ask two questions so
with respect to the you know the vibrant
BDS work we see growing in the United
States and with that comes the
opposition to the BDS work particularly
in the language that people use so if
you support BDS your anti-israeli and
literally like all I think the not the
what's that post the post the paper that
starts out with page six on that paper I
was reading recently that you know the
the the boycott divestment campaign with
respect to the coop here in in Brooklyn
and it failed and this anti-israeli
measure failed so i guess my question is
with respect to the language how do we
really sort of move shift the disc the
dialogue in the way we frame this work
because i think the opposition will
continue to grow and this really like
you know dichotomous it's like you if
you support BDS work than your
anti-israeli and it's just you know as a
palestinian-american i just really
struggle with like always being pushed
back and I know that and with respect to
the abolition movement here you know I
just I don't even think we're even at a
place to talk about Palestinian like
prisoners in the way that we position
ourselves to talk about prisoners here
because you know the assumption is with
all prisoners that they did something
wrong right but I think with the
Palestinian prisoners this is this
notion that it's acceptable to have
collective punishment for an entire
people so how do we how do we get ship
that dialogue and then build those
connections with with the activism
abolitionist movement here and then one
last question this one I guess is is to
professor Davis which is you know so in
your in your book no more prisons
critiquing the prison
at the prisons in this country you you
specifically talked about you know the
13th amendment um what what sort of
parallel this is I guess to anyone was
sort of parallel do we have in Israel
with the laws that specifically codify
and create the legal system by which one
can legitimately incarcerate for
security reasons Palestinians sorry for
being long-winded thank you thank you
all ok one more ok I'll try cuz they
won't be able to remember everyone um so
I'm just wondering in respect to think
about pink washing and Israel what is
the role of queer identities in prison
so thank you come next week okay can we
any buddy want to answer any of those ah
whoever wants to go first well I think
yeah the first question is gonna use
that Mike can everybody hear ya I think
it's important that you point out the
degree to which we often routinely
accept modes of security that appear to
be less harmful but as a matter of fact
they prepare us to accept you know
larger with a premier istics accepts a
security state and I I'll just tell this
story that i constantly think about many
many years ago I was in Northern Ireland
and and I I was invited by women
involved in the civil rights movement
there and I I couldn't understand how
they could basically submit to all of
the security processes and whatever you
go into a mall your purse has two bees
and then years later after 911 when we
acquired the habit of dis robing and
doing all kinds of things in order to
get on a plane it became clear that that
that if we're not if we're not conscious
of the degree to which we are also
implicated we continue to be responsible
for the in a larger more harmful modes
of security now I the the question that
was asked by the second per I think I'll
do the first in the second one in the
know what you all do this before but the
second question which has to do with
disability issues prisoners and
disability and I would I can tell you
that within a year within less than a
year anthology edited by a woman who is
she should be receiving a PhD soon you
know maybe this June who's an
anti-zionist Jewish activist whose name
is Leah ben-moshe she's editing also a
collection of articles on disability and
the question of the prison and in
response to the other question I'll just
make another plug for another book of
one of my graduate students did that's
called captive genders which is about
the trans experience within prisoners
and not only about the experience of
trans prisoners but about the importance
of taking up the issue of gender
non-conforming in relationship to the
apparatus of the prison allowing us to
recognize the extent to which the prison
it's
encourages and promotes gender binaries
and has an impact on larger ideological
formations and not only on those who
sustain the direct effect of transphobia
behind bars and his name is his name is
Eric Stanley and it's called captive
genders it's an ice anthology just wanna
push a little bit what you said because
I think that even before talking about
this state as a security state or even
if it was a really democratic liberal
state it is a state that is should be
called as it is it's a settler colonial
state and it was just constituted by the
extermination of the natives so it's
even if it's not a security state so we
need to ask also these questions and I
don't have any other thing to say but
it's an iron um I think um well first of
all when we talk about disability we
have to talk about disabilities that are
produced through violent treatment and
torture and then we can talk about
disabilities that pre-exists that so my
sense is that there are two different
questions one or one has to do with
physical restrictions that emerged as a
as a result of torture or violent
treatment and the second one has to do
with whether appropriate health care is
provided and at least in my readings
about Palestinian prisoners appropriate
health care is not provided nor is there
anything that we might remotely think of
as of accessibility it's a kind of joke
thinking about the way prisons are
are constructed to make sure there is no
accessibility for anyone when when one
seeks to defend the BDS movement and is
told that it is anti-israel I think
there is really only one response that
is possible and that is to say that the
BDS movement is a struggle to achieve
justice and and that it has three main
goals of one is the end to the
occupation the second is the
institutionalization of equality for
Jewish and non-jewish Israeli citizens
and the third is the right of return and
those are all fundamental issues of
equality of justice and if to be when
people say it's anti-israel they and
don't respond to those issues then
they're implicitly saying that one needs
to defend Israel even in the face of the
in justices it performs at which point
they're left with a contradictory and
appalling political position so my my my
short answer is you do not engage that
question directly as about as a and and
and you will know how quickly the
argument can move to our you 4get aru
pro-israel you anti-israel as if we're
talking about soccer teams right and
we're actually talking about fundamental
issues of justice and it has to be
brought back to that don't let it get
absorbed into the pro anti-israel
framework it's very very important to
resist that as for queer identities in
prison I don't know I do know that the
word queer is a complicated word in the
Palestinian context but if you look at
Palestinian queers for BDS or L cos you
will see there that queer is less an
identity than a political analysis that
refuses to accept homophobia and refuses
to accept occupation and
will not trade one for the other okay
and it also refuses the idea that
Palestine is somehow a haven for
homophobia and Israel is not which is I
think finally a a racist and ignorant
claim but I think we also have to be
clear about how sexuality functions in
different ways it doesn't always circle
around or focus on or become defined by
the idea of identity and it certainly
doesn't always become focused on or
organized by the idea of openness and
once we once we put those two things in
perspective we might have a different
conversation about sexuality politics in
Palestine can I just also say that
there's a pink washing event next
wednesday at tuesday the 10th whatever
the April 10th is at eight o'clock at
Barnard so you should look out for those
signs if you want to pursue that further
I think we want to hear from a few more
people thank you hi um so first of all
thank you all so much it's been really
amazing I actually want to thank
professor Davis I was actually about to
ask about trans experiences in prison
and then spoke about it so I i was
wondering addressing to the panel and
generally speak more about the ways the
weight of gendered forms of violence in
the prison and particularly the ways
that we narrate gender what does it mean
to talk about Palestinian women or
Palestinian men or doesn't mean to talk
about women and men in prison and how
how do we narrate trans experiences when
part of the trans struggle is even being
able to claim the struggle to even be
able to claim the identity of the
subject position of being a man or being
a woman so how do we narrate those
within experiences of gendered violence
and gender segregated spaces you know
under under a military occupation or
under the prison industrial complex
thank you thank you we'll take two more
mm-hmm I thank you all for coming um
being a an Israeli veteran who was both
pro-israel and pro-palestinian obviously
your presentations were very very
powerful to me and I do appreciate you
guys very much for coming that said
given the idea that a non prisoner
society or non prison society is a
beautiful ideal given the current
situation more importantly just as if
the Israeli side must be held
accountable so to most malicious acts by
Palestinian side also be held
accountable what would you all believe
would be a proper alternative to the
situation that clearly needs to change
thank you
hi I'd like to thank you again also for
your invaluable contributions today I
suppose my question is about space about
architecture and it's about the prison
as a structure itself I don't know about
the United States but in Israel at least
there's a tendency a lot of historians
have been working on this of kind of
symbolic leery appropriating particular
spaces which have resonance to
Palestinians so it's not uncommon that
actual sites where prisons are built or
sometimes mental asylums that those
actual sites had a special resonance to
Palestine in the past so I Siberia seen
for example where there's a famous
Israeli mental asylum in that space and
my question is in relation to prisons
that are like that what kind of an
effect would you say that has
essentially on the on the prisoners and
on society at large that there's this
kind of reappropriation going on thank
you take any of those Lena didn't take
me well I just
because isn't my approach would be how
if you're asking about Palestinian
prisoners how they also Reese ignis I
this because I have a lot of interviews
with expel Essene prisoners who for
example there were one person political
prisoners he's from Haifa and his family
was expelled in 1948 from Haifa and they
were living like in there West Bank and
then when he was imprisoned he was put
in a prison in Haifa so for him this he
was telling that how he felt that this
was like a way to get back to return to
his hometown and again it's how very
significations of these think the other
thing I had an interview with an
Islamist political activist and during
his interrogation he was interrogated in
Alma Scooby a which is an interrogation
Center in Jerusalem and he he went under
a very prolong interrogation and
everyone was supporting him because he
was tortured very violently and in his
accounts he's saying that for him this
space was this time was being in the
holy land where he felt that he is so
close to God so it's also interesting
not just reading and prison and
imprisonment from the perspective of
power also trying to read them from the
perspective of those who are resisting
because i think that the engagement with
those who are resisting will will also
change a lot of things and will also
encourage us to be in solidarity with
resistors and not just focusing on their
technologies of power
um I I wanted to say to the gentleman
who claimed to be pro Israel
pro-palestinian I really do think the
pro thing really has to go I mean I just
I don't understand it it says if we're
in a you know world pom-pom girls or you
know we're rooting for our soccer team I
mean I understand what it means to rid
for a soccer team but these are not
soccer teams and they're not they're not
two parties who meet each other on equal
terrain we are actually talking about an
ongoing situation of settler colonialism
that uses and deploys carceral politics
to reproduce itself to reproduce itself
through time and space in very very
particular ways so we have to ask you
know when we talk about malicious acts
for instance is the bombing of gaza and
is that a malicious act or is that um or
is that state-sponsored violence that is
considered to be legitimate and a
legitimate security act whereas those
who resist such bombings or who resist
being dispossessed or expelled or are
and are understood to be committing
crimes we have to think about how the
language of crime and punishment is
ideological in the sense that angela has
made very very clear and and how that
relates to the state monopoly on
violence right and how that gets called
legitimate how it gets called security
and then what becomes crime in
relationship to that state violence and
and and and it's it's it's why we can't
we can't I think easily accept that
framework for the adjudication of the
problem we have to ask politically what
what what does the language of crime do
and who can become criminal and who is
already and from the start exonerated
from criminality one question I have and
I think it's for Lina really is I really
enjoyed the description of resistance
end of some moved in particular the the
double pneus of not confessing and not
acknowledging but I was wondering
whether that can I understand it as a
practice of Risa go fine and even as a
bodily practice of Risa go fine is it
also a mode of solidarity how do we
understand it as something that is
produced serially among many people who
are nevertheless sometimes forcibly
spatially separated from one another how
do we think about solidarity in that
resistance prak practice well you was
one person okay well i think that
thinking about some wood and again in in
both there as a political strategy and
as a theoretical philosophical frame and
i'm trying also to think recognition and
what does recognition mean but then i
think also following the life that
smooth talk for itself we can see how
smooth was not just like an ownership of
the one who's practicing smooth smooth
through the 80s Early 90s became
something that is the ownership of the
whole community people were if someone
was arrested everyone would think about
those who are arrested would be waiting
to hear because if someone practiced
smooth this mean that this potentiality
of revolutionary subjectivity was
actualized within this moment and this
means a victory to all the community the
other thing it became there's a
genealogy for smooth but also it became
part of the public culture you'll hear
hundreds of songs about some old you'll
you'll see that in a specific
areas and people who practiced somewhat
and the interrogation became in a sense
the heroes which in that area so people
who are from marginalized classes our
geographical areas became the represent
earth of the Palestinian revolutionary
subjectivity through their smooth so
smooth affected a lot of it so of
changes the last thing I'll say it it's
also affected their ethical intimate
relations and and all of this is
intertwined with politics it's like
these connectivity to the comrades to to
practice samad means to beer to bear the
torture in order not to provide
information about comrades which the one
who's under torture through their body
flesh and blood they need to protect the
collective of the comrades the community
and the resistant movement so there is
something that is beyond the singular
who is practicing okay well I know there
was the question about gender that that
you raised hmm and I just want to say a
couple of words I of course there are
many ways in which one could approach
your question but I'm i'm going to say
something that's that's sort of hard to
say particularly in the context of of
palestine and that is you know how do we
recognize the gendered violence both in
terms of the state violence and in terms
of violence that happens in intimate
relationships often perpetrated
precisely by
those who have played such an important
role in the struggle for freedom and I
mean I think that's an important
question about gender it's related to
the issue of the gendered character of
imprisonment precisely because when we
look at prison populations political
prisoners and other prisoners all over
the world they're overwhelmingly male
and we often assume that it's simply
because women don't do the things that
cause them to end up in prison whether
it's a political act or whether it's a
criminal act but I think that if we if
we again dis articulate the crime and
punishment or political acts and
punishment we begin to see that there
are other reasons why people end up the
behind bars some people do and some
people don't and that that as a matter
of fact there's a kind of punishment
that's inflicted on women in a way that
represents a kind of delegation by the
state to punish women within private
context so I think it's important to
look at violence against women which we
tend to think we can eradicate simply by
criminalizing it and the fact is that
over the last 30 years or so the
criminalization of violence against
women has led to many many more
perpetrators of violence against women
and landing in prison but it is not at
all had an impact on the incidence of
violence against women so I think it
would be really important especially
especially within a context like
Palestine I think to try to address some
of those really hard questions and
develop modes of activism that allow us
to be attentive
22 both expressions of violence and then
the other question about accountability
I totally agree with you Judith about
the soccer team approach but at the same
time I think we can think about
accountability and there is there's
accountability that doesn't necessarily
have to be resolved by or addressed by
the institution of the prison and I
thought about this this story I heard
about a South African woman during the
truth and reconciliation hearings whose
husband and sons were killed by a South
African I think it was an either
policeman or millet some official and so
when she went before when they went
before the truth and reconciliation
panel she was asked what she wanted what
she wanted to be done to this man who
had had killed her husband and I think
it was two sons and she said well I have
no one left and so I want you to come to
my house every day I want you to provide
me with some companionship which I've
lost and she went on and and I mean of
course it was absolutely unimaginable
but this is what she wanted this is how
she thought that this man could be made
accountable for his ass and I think it's
really important to begin to imagine
other ways of achieving justice rather
than always rely on vengeance and
retribution I'm a little worried about
the time and I wonder if we could leave
ourselves with those last words and
maybe do a little bit informally
afterwards and appreciate it if you
would give up your questions and thank
the panelists
much for this